this question is from an army vet that
was in Ramadi in 2004 you know he noted
that to me yeah
which is good to hear yeah sometimes a
curse and there's no respect yeah just
started jujitsu boom I'm a very I'm a
very step action drill oriented guy I
blame the field artillery officer basic
course today while training an
instructor was talking to me about the
flow and creativity and improvisation
that is needed I'm assuming it comes
with time any ideas on helping to get
that way or sorry any ideas on helping
to get away from the step action drill
mindset or just let it go or do you just
let it come yeah that's that's that's
great and I know you've seen people like
this and it's I see him all the time
it's people that have the personality
that is like an engineer personality
okay what do I do
step one mm-hmm step two step three step
four what you tell me the steps look
quit all this conceptual stuff tell me
the steps to do and actually Higgs was
deaf he he was describing a guy that we
trained with and in the way he described
this scenario he's talking about this
specific guy who kind of fits this mold
and this was this guy was coming to
train with us and gonna be one of our
students and Higgs goes yeah you know he
he's really good he's got you know he
trained super hard he's strong and um
he's got a very stubborn jujitsu mind
which I got a kick out of it it's true
but it's this kind of thing where you
know you just want to know the steps
then you just want to apply them and by
the way if you want to teach about
options mm-hmm tell me what the options
are then you know an option one 1a 1b 1c
they want to have that mindset for
everything so that stops you right we
want to get beyond that we want to get
to it's just like a person playing a
musical instrument yeah you can teach
them all the notes but they need to
figure out how to play music right they
figure out how to create
music that's the difference I always say
this when um if you go to a Guitar
Center which is a guitar store in
America and you put up a sign that says
you know I need someone that can play
the following twenty-seven albums
note-for-note
you'll get you'll get a hundred phone
calls if you put a website that said
that because you're gonna record an
album or whatever but of all those
people not all of them can create a
musical song that is original and good
and all that so there's the difference
right this is the difference between
like a normal jiu-jitsu player who's by
the book and and then you know a person
that creates the top level guys that are
creating new moves all the time yeah so
that's what we want to become and it's
not just to be a top level guy it's also
to be it's also how you improve it's how
you get better you got to figure out how
to match the how to put the notes of
jiu-jitsu together so and on top of that
it's the same thing with combat it's the
same thing with doing an assault it's
the same thing with an immediate action
drill it's the same thing with moving
down a hallway if all you know and all
you can do in your brain is follow the
steps and follow the standard operating
procedures as much as I talk about
standard operating procedures being
necessary and mandatory if all you know
how to do is follow them you will fall
short and you will come into a situation
where they're not gonna work and now
you're gonna you're gonna be done you're
gonna stop you're not gonna know what to
do that happens to you all the time yeah
so we need to free our mind that's what
we needed you know you need to free your
mind and how do you do that well first
of all discipline equals freedom so we
want to have the discipline which means
we do need to drill the moves it means
we do need to learn the moves it means
we do need to repeat them over and over
again so that we get good at them we do
need to do that but then we've got to
set the mind free and how do you do that
I mean go outside of your comfort zone
for one and a lot of guys everyone does
this where you say you know what man I'm
getting everyone in this one move I'm
gonna stop doing it I'm gonna do another
move I'm not gonna get 18 anyone feel 2
months you know I'm not gonna commit
recommend me yeah
yeah so go outside your comfort zone
work on some that work on some move that
you don't do throw out your best
submission and don't use it so now
you're gonna be going through all these
different different we got to go for
different moves you got to get creative
same thing with hitting hitting your
move from different positions that ya
supposed to work yeah like you for
instance you just talked about the
guillotine I'm a fan of the guillotine
but I do gay teens in weird places I
mean I have people tap out to my
guillotine when I am when we're in weird
positions that no you should like but no
one's ever been tapped out and they're
like I don't know how I just got tapped
out how did you do that yeah how did you
I was you know across the side and I was
yeah you were but I had this going on so
try your moves from different positions
random positions do try things that
shouldn't work too right try a move
that's a top move try it from the bottom
try moving it to move from the bottom
try it from the top try from the side
drive from cross side try from butterfly
guard try these different moves and
you'll start to create more the other
thing that will free your mind is when
you stop worrying about tapping people
out and getting dapped out ya worry
about progress worry about creativity
try and be more creative and if all
you're worried about is not tapping out
your progress is gonna be slow and if
all you're worried about is tapping the
other guy out your progress is gonna be
slow mm-hmm
if all you're worried about is losing
your progress is gonna be slow so that's
it
and I will actually one more thing I
would say there's a kind of a dichotomy
here in the 1:1 side you want to be able
to turn your brain completely off and
just do whatever happens mmm and at the
same time you want to force your mind to
make yourself do particular moves right
like so go in one of those if you're
gonna think think about new moves or
turn your brain completely off and let
things happen as they come you know and
then free your mind turning your brain
off and letting the moves kind of it's
almost like you're letting them move
happen on its own kind of thing that it
comes with time more and more you know
like when you first start that's
probably not really
gonna happen much yeah yeah and also
like an example of that is if you were
teaching a class and you said hey Jocko
come here and you know I'm gonna do this
sweep on you and you do the sweep in
like I would defend it immediately
mm-hmm and I go sorry man and we I'd
have to sit there not defend the move so
that you could show the sweep right you
see them saying like it's a complete
instinct for me to stop that move or
it's a complete instinct for me to grab
your hand or stop you know so that's the
way that's the way it works you want
that yeah well you want it to be an
instinct you want all your moves to be
instinctual these if you have to think
about them in real situations you if the
other person is good then you have to
think about what you're gonna do you're
gonna lose yeah because they're not
thinking they're they're getting that
quarter second it takes a quarter second
to process right when we used to you
know shooting pistols it takes a quarter
second for you to see the target
according second to get to your holster
in a quarter second to get to go now and
get the shot out of this three-quarters
of a second so if you all you had to do
is just drop shoot you a quarter seconds
gone or if you have the gun in your hand
a quarter seconds gone so actually Greg
train the other did that the other day
and I fought about that so I that's why
this is fresh in my mind like he grabbed
my hand real quick and I was like oh he
did that sort of like I used to go for
my holster because you can go as fast as
you possibly can to your holster once
you get to your holster you got to slow
down yeah but you can go so fast your
holster that's why I used to make ups or
something you know as much as I could do
my holster and then get and then once
you get there you're done you gotta get
frontside focus but Greg train moved
that fast trying to grab my hat like
that nose like I don't start doing that
those are doing that again dude a little
speed work on it yes oh yeah free your
mind it back to the point here and
thanks for your service yeah that way of
learning I think it's it's actually
pretty prevalent when you first start
because you don't know you don't know
the move you don't know why it works you
know that it works because your teachers
teaching it to you but you don't know
like why it works so it's all right just
show me tell me the steps to do it walk
through it you learn another move you
learn this move you learn you know he
refines your technique you go roll you
find out okay that doesn't work when I
do it this way or you don't know why it
doesn't work so you could ask and I'm
the kind of learner
that I will i actually the first thing I
want to know is how does this work yeah
I want to know that before I know even
the steps yeah and a lot of times I
teach that way I'm teaching like here's
the concept of what we're trying to make
happen yeah we're trying to get their
weight over here so here's how we're
gonna get their weight over there now
once we get their weight over there
that's easy to say hey I know you and
you do this slip your hips here and
you're gonna be on their back or
whatever the case may be but for me that
can the concept of what you're trying to
make happen is what I like to think
about and it's what I like to teach and
that's the same thing with combat you
know I'm there's moves that you're gonna
do on the battlefield but conceptually
what are you trying to make happen you
know cover and move is cover move is the
most simple one you can cover and move
an infinite number of ways but if you
don't cover and move you're gonna die
and as long as you have one of those
millions of different ways of covering
and moving and I healed like some guys
would get really particular in might
when I was born I was running training
guys but hey you can't do that
and I would say well what did they do
that you didn't like well you know he he
should have gone he should have moved
first well did the other guy cover him
well yeah well why should the other guy
I've gone first well that's the way we
taught him okay well does it make sense
can you give me a reason not really are
they covering and moving yes all right I
think they're good yeah you're right
they probably are mm-hmm so yeah yeah
that's um it goes along too very much it
seems like anyway what you're saying
about telling people why they're doing
what they're doing
yes so it's essentially the same thing
jujitsu you're right because if you just
say grab their arm and pull it into your
you know neck so you can sweep them but
what you really want to tell them is
like listen they're gonna put their hand
out here for base right balance so what
you want to do is you want to be ready
to move it or move it and you only have
to get it you only have to take their
base away for a quarter second you know
I say that a lot
I say that a lot like people in jujitsu
they try and move
they try and they try and affect the
other person's body for an extended
period of time for ten seconds yeah yeah
for twelve seconds they try and bring
the hand into them so they can sweep
them and they hold it there for five
seconds I'm gonna hold it for a quarter
second because that's all it takes for a
sweep to happen that's all it takes for
an armlock to happen that's all it takes
we're getting there happen is that one
quarter second it's a quarter second as
all you're trying to do and once you
want you are winning quarter second
quarter second quarter second now you're
1mm you know but again if I do feel like
that it's a this is I mean it's a it's
probably I would imagine you it's a it's
a spectrum with learning just to like
you know how you say some guys they just
tend to learn that way yes and then some
guys tend to learn the other way you
know yeah yeah both ways and I think in
the beginning I know was for me and most
people that I've seen in the beginning
you just you tend to learn that way show
me the stuff you don't know that
everything you don't know that you do
you know even me I mean uh I'm uh I'm
probably pretty far in the extreme
spectrum of let me understand the
concept yeah and plus you're advanced
though I think when I was the beginning
Oh beginning even I was like okay well
how is this working like I was like show
me how do you I was thinking how did
that happen how why am i tapping right
now yeah how can I not move you know
that's what I was thinking yeah
I wasn't thinking show me the movement I
was thinking what is going on yeah yeah
and there's actually high-level guys you
can tell by the way that they teach or
the way that they yeah by the way that
they teach or train you can tell that
there's got high-level guys on both
sides
there's high-level guys that are like
like for instance guys that drill all
the time those are the guys that are
mechanical nothing wrong with it they
win world champions champions so with
that you know and then there's guys that
don't drill but they roll like crazy and
their games will reflect that Geoff
Glover you know Geoff Glover Dean Lister
same thing let's get you don't see those
guys doing a lot of drilling it's not
that they never do it but if you compare
them to let's say who's in who's a
little world champion truck I mean even
galvan god I was a driller and he just
will
drill and at least from what I've seen
you know from what I've seen of you know
videos of him training he's working to
move and you're like okay that's awesome
guys dominate dominates fantastic
jujitsu yeah and I think at the end when
you become that good even if that's your
primarily method of learning or training
or whatever I think when you gain
ultimately like the understanding of
okay I see I see why this is important
to do this or important not to do this
whatever even if you are uncle driller
the creativity part is it's almost like
it's uncontainable it'll all yeah even
like golf outward they do drill a lot
maybe I wasn't who made the DVD that was
literally called drill to win it was
like one somebody that's really good
made it drill to win right so that's the
kind of attitude on again that's how you
get better
right gentling drilling drilling and
what the the thing is to what - to
respond to what you just said is fact
discipline equals freedom if you drill
and drill and drill and you make those
moves so natural the need of free gonna
come from all over the place you know so
you're right the end state is gonna be
the same but there's gonna be people on
all ends of that learning spectrum and
training spectrum yeah they're gonna be
all over the place
yeah and some people like like I don't
like to drill don't enjoy it mm-hmm
maybe I did at some point don't remember
but I would rather roll yeah I think a
lot of its again what in the beginning
it seems like what kind of learner you
are is gonna show itself way more oh
yeah just as far as even for reverence
and how you pick things up then a lot
goes with the fact that there's a lot to
pick up when you begin you stop there's
so much to learn so you're like well you
absolutely have to drill I hope no one's
listening me go to a jogger whose rules
no you have a drill when you start off
you have oh yeah you have to learn the
body mechanics of it yeah so yes I am
talking about a more advanced - and it I
think ultimately just like how you said
though I think that in time once you
start learning the moves and is given
the fact that you are rolling though you
know some people don't learn the move
then they'll go home oh yeah it's rare
but when you you learn whatever this
guard pass to the arm bar combo
and you know the steps and crap here put
your knee here whatever the guys your
your training partner your partner for
the drill or whatever is you know he's
letting you be doing but you become a
ten out of ten in the drill you get so
good at that drill your ten out of ten
when you go to apply for real you're
still gonna fail yes exactly right
because you don't know all the all these
dynamic variables coming at you so
that's when you gain the understanding
yes that's when more question is gonna
pop up okay that need to be answered you
answer and boom there's your learning
right there so the drill is good yeah
for the body one can especially at the
beginning because you don't know you
know like IV you're talking about your
all your hands arms legs hips head
everything arm position well what's even
more critical than those things because
all those things are visit visible you
you can see them the things that are
harder to teach and to understand is the
weight distribution and the balanced
distribution those are the things that
you can't you cannot see and there's
also one more which is the tension
distribution because when I'm pulling on
your art when I grab your wrist when I'm
holding your wrist I could be putting
tension in 360 degrees right if I'm
holding your wrist I could be moving it
I could be putting tension now no one
could tell which way I'm putting pushing
or pulling or lifting or dragging no one
can tell because your arm isn't moving
right but the tension you can't see the
balance you can't see and the and the
the weight distribution you can't see
any of those things and that's why it's
very hard to teach him yeah you know and
then really the only way and again back
to this thing it comes with time is when
you roll live with someone then you're
gonna see all these different subtle
different scenarios where the stuff you
learned dean was teaching an armlock the
other day you know like a basic arm walk
which I've probably sat there in the
class of his and been his Bennis dummy a
thousand times and like somebody asked a
question and then he was do used doing
the arm walk to me and I realized
something that he was doing that I never
noticed before and it's it's he's
pulling the arm towards his head
basically like pulling it pulling it
towards his yeah and I mean in a pretty
stream way mm-hmm and I realized how
incredibly effective it was it's it's it
wasn't holding it he's been holding it
it wasn't and so like those little
things like that I've I've been his
dummy and maybe you know just because he
always being his dummy he he didn't
didn't remember or didn't think about
doing that step but the way the question
got asked and and even when he's unlock
me thousands of times he you know I
didn't notice it you know I just thought
man he's got a tight arm lock right but
it's like okay that was the detail and I
never you could watch him do that move
to me a thousand times or anyone else a
thousand times then you wouldn't be able
to know that detail unless either he
told it to you or you felt it you know
and there's that's the thing that's
crazy about jujitsu there's all kinds of
little little aspects like that balance
weight intention that you just can't you
can't see visually you can feel them you
can feel them but even if I say hey echo
actually you can't feel all of it
because you can't feel where I'm putting
my weight if I'm putting my weight into
the mat you can tell if I'm heavy over
here you can't feel that you don't know
where I'm heavy
you just know what I feel heavy but
where's my weight gonna be now if I my
weight is on you you can feel it mm-hmm
passengers yes quiet before we have just
a jiu jitsu podcast yeah